you guys just look like you're having so
much fun in your engagement like are you
guys enjoying it as much as we feel it
and see it yes yeah we are you know and
like it we're so thrilled to be on the
cover of the not i'm talking about it
here on on your show drew our show
because it's important to us to share
our love with the world and and we made
a conscious decision to do that because
why well because you know growing up an
immigrant from dominican republic and
him being a little farm boy from mount
vernon you know we never saw that and
it's important to actually have that
representation out there and you know
just value that any anyone can actually
have that as well so yeah so excited we
didn't growing up think about that we
didn't even know we didn't even dream
about getting married one day because it
wasn't even an option for us you know
and so we think by sharing our love
story and and showing it to everyone
maybe there's a little kid out there who
who can look at us and go oh my god i
deserve that i deserve love